ce sera le plus grand télescope spatial
jamais mise en orbite est l'un des
instruments les plus sophistiqué de
l'histoire scientifique moderne tout
dans le james webb est disproportionnée
vingtaine d'années de travaux 10
milliards de dollars de budget et
surtout ce miroir géant beaucoup plus
performant que celui de hambourg
james webb c'est vraiment une
technologie unique et très complexe et
c'est la première fois qu'on rie convoi
réussir à mettre un télescope de cette
taille là 6 - 5 m de diamètre dans
l'espace le télescope sera lancée par l'
agence européenne le 31 octobre prochain
à partir de la guyane française
son point d'observation se trouvera un
million et demi de kilomètres soit
quatre fois la distance entre la terre
et la lune
loin de la pollution lumineuse et des
turbulences atmosphériques pour le
protéger contre la chaleur du soleil ce
réflecteurs grand comme un terrain de
tennis
de l'autre côté de cet écran il fera
moins 400 degrés fahrenheit
la température idéale pour les
instruments du jane's web qui sont
conçus pour détecter les objets très
chaud et très lointain le robot travail
dans le visible alors tandis que le
james webb
c'est un télescope qui travaillent plus
dans l'infrarouge alors ça nous permet
de vraiment exploré différents avec loïc
albert et olivia line stéphane pelletier
fait partie d'un groupe de chercheurs de
l'université de montréal qui vient
d'obtenir une plage d'utilisation du
télescope spatial dans son cas une
douzaine d'heures pour examiner waes
127bis une très lointaine planète
gazeuse géant
pensez à jupiter qui est cinq fois plus
légère mais deux fois plus grosse en
volume alors c'est vraiment une
exoplanète très étendue olbia l'ema
obtenu un bloc de 54 heures pour scruter
trappistes de 1u systèmes planétaires
inhabituel et possiblement porteur de
vie la piste est vraiment spécial entre
autres parce que au moins trois de ces
exoplanètes sont dans la zone habitable
du système donc c'est la zone où la
température est juste adéquat pour que
de l'eau liquide puisse exister à la
surface la recherche de formes de vie
extraterrestre est l'un des grands
objectifs du télescope spatial
on sait pas si les planètes de
trappistes un en une atmosphère donc son
pourrait la prendre avec les données
jingwei on pourrait aussi aussi
déterminer quelles molécules sont dans
les atmosphères de ces planètes l'heure
l'autre objectif c'est l'étude des
origines de l'univers grâce à
l'observation des galaxies très
lointaines
ces objets-là émettent de l'infrarouge a
pas d'autre moyen que d'observer en
infrarouge si on veut observer les
galaxies les plus lointaines et plus
faibles c'est en infrarouge chasse passe
le hic albert va utiliser le james webb
pour analyser durant une quarantaine
d'heures un type des toiles très peu
lumineuse une naine brune
il fait également partie de l'équipe
canadienne qui contribuent au projet
james webb
j'ai participé au design optique et à la
construction au test de certaines pièces
d'optique pour notre instrument canadien
une des quatre caméras sur le télescope
c'est maintenant une caméra à la caméra
denis risques et canadiennes donc là
l'universite montréal est impliqué dans
ce projet là quelle sera la durée de vie
du james webb
au moins cinq ans mais pas plus d'une
dizaine d'années
c'est normal le télescope devra être
repositionné fréquemment dans l'espace
et sa réserve de carburant est limité
son temps sera donc extrêmement précieux
et ça les futurs utilisateurs en sont
bien conscients j'ai vraiment été très
content je crie ou d'amour dans ma
chambre
c'était vraiment exceptionnel je suis
honoré d'avoir l'opportunité d'utiliser
son immense télescope et je vais essayer
de faire plus que je peux avec les
données ici normand grondin reste du
canada
mourir